so this is an interesting question
that's come up recently
autocad or archicad
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
recently we discussed the differences
and similarities between
revit and archicad however today we
really want to focus on the differences
between autocad and archicad now these
two are very similar
but very different software and there
might be
a very specific reason why you're
looking at one or the other now if
you've been following my channel for a
while now
you know i've been stuck in a cast
for a little bit i hope that was in
frame otherwise that's just going to
look
like me being an idiot lifting my leg
but i rocked you my achilles a couple
weeks ago and it's slowly recovering
slowly healing
by the time this uploads i'll be going
to specialist tomorrow probably
so hopefully some good news there and
next time you see me on youtube
hopefully some good news but for the
simple fact that i'm still making these
videos making sure to get some good
content out to you guys make sure you
like and subscribe to this video okay so
let's start by talking about the actual
price differences between these two
softwares
autocad and archicad are both very
powerful
but yet very differently priced software
if i can put it that way
for example autocad only costs 350
a month to get going it is an ongoing
subscription that you have to pay for
every single month
and there's no way out of it if you stop
paying for it you stop using it
you can also pay 2 805 roughly
yearly if you don't want to pay a
monthly membership this is
one way to just flip your costs up front
but it depends on your cash flow if
you're going to be able to do something
like this now with archicad there is a
big difference here
archicad you pay a very large chunk
up front to have the license and then
you pay a yearly
fee to renew or to upgrade if you want
to
if you don't want to upgrade to the next
license you don't have to pay anything
more
so for example in australia it's been a
few years since we purchased ours but it
was roughly five and a half thousand to
six thousand dollars
per license of archicad now if we
decided
not to upgrade for 10 years for some
reason
over those 10 years it would have only
cost this the original investment if you
do decide to upgrade it's roughly about
700 australian to upgrade to the next
version
now thanks to the guys who commented on
my last video comparing revit and
archicad
i actually have some really good figures
from around the world of how much
archicad costs
so if you're interested in the uk it is
about 2
950 pound plus tax with a 400
pound yearly upgrade fee it's 3750 euro
once off or 150 euro upgrade fee every
year
and it's about 3970
american so all of these if you
translate it and do the
currency conversion they're all roughly
about the same but regardless
of that fact archicad is still a very
very large
upfront cost basically it's two years
almost three years of paying for autocad
just to get archicad straight away now
that fact alone could have just swayed
your decision
knowing that you have to pay a bucket
load up front versus a couple hundred
dollars every month
might be the tipping point for you if
price isn't your main concern let's dive
into this a little bit more
let's take a look at the formatting and
the program itself
as we all know or probably should know
autocad is a dwg
based format it produces all of its
drawings
in predominantly dwg form obviously you
can export these files as a whole
different host of different
file types and it depends on the
software that you're trying to
use with autocad so it does give you
some freedom there
however dwg is its main purpose and the
more common
export file type that you will be
sharing with other people
the limitations of dwg are pretty simple
it's all 2d lines
a dwg file is floor plans elevation
sections the good thing about this is it
means whatever you can really draw and
imagine on paper
there's a good chance you can create it
on autocad which takes away from the
limitations of autocad
autocad isn't limited to just
architecture or engineering
you can do absolutely anything if you
want to design watches phone cases
furniture lighting cameras
absolutely anything that you can think
of again if you can draw on a piece of
paper
you can create it on autocad but again
we come back to the fact that it is
predominantly 2d lines
and if you don't know what you're doing
or if you're just starting out you're
going to be drawing 2d lines for a very
long time
until you figure out the 3d capabilities
inside autocad whereas when we look at
archicad it's a pln file
it's a custom file exclusive to archicad
you can't go ahead and import that pln
file into
autocad or any other program it just
won't work
you can however export your files to
dwgs or to any other file format that
you might need
for your consultants or your clients the
thing here with archicad as it is in the
name
is it's architecture related anything to
do with architecture it's very very good
at
anything not to do with architecture
well not so much
now archicad isn't specific to
architecture and architects
it has implemented the engineering side
of things a lot more over the past few
years
so you can actually use this software as
an engineer
but more than likely most engineers are
still either on revit
or autocad for the simplicity sake of 2d
lines one of the best things about
archicad
is when you start using it everything's
in 3d so for example if you were to open
up the template straight away never used
archicad before and just start drawing
some walls
go to 3d mode all of a sudden you'd have
almost a whole house developed
within maybe a five minute learning
curve you can put together a very basic
full three-dimensional four-sided house
with
roof doors windows the work for example
autocad
is predominantly a 2d program like i've
said before
which means everything has to be
manually calculated
you have to count the number of doors
the number of windows create your own
schedules
create your own excel documents and kind
of
understand the whole building as a whole
on a whole separate layer
because again it's either a block or
it's a 2d
object but in some way shape or form
it isn't all scheduled in and built in
as powerful as it is on archicad
so for example the same thing if you
were to put in 104 doors into a project
and obviously your template was set up
correctly you can quickly and easily
list all those 104 doors understand what
door handles they have
what hinges they have what color the
door needs to be what the architraves
are
you can go into all the details is a
hollow core is it solid core
and actually give that information to a
builder if you're a student watching the
channel
first of all thank you so much for
watching i hope your career goes really
well and you're loving it so far
but as a student you probably don't have
to worry about scheduling
and details to this level it is
something you should know and should
learn because eventually
everybody wants what they designed to be
built to actually build this development
properly
well there's a number of things that are
going to happen they're either going to
quote it too low
and then sting you with a whole bunch of
variations or your client with a whole
bunch of variations throughout the
process
or they're just not going to want to
price it anymore because there isn't
enough
information on the documents themselves
so they're just guessing
okay so now let's talk about the design
and documentation stage
of architecture considering this is
usually about 50 to 60 percent of the
time
spent on a project and 50 to 60 percent
of your
fee as an architect engineer whatever
you might be
there is a lot of time spent on this
section
autocad can document anything and i mean
genuinely you can
document anything you want you can
understand every single corner and
crevice
of a tunnel if you want to or how the
leg on a furniture
chair is moulded i don't know whatever
you can basically
imagine you can document in some way
shape or form on autocad
and that is a huge win for the software
on archicad if it's architectural
you can document it if it isn't well
then you're probably going to waste a
hell of a lot of time trying to figure
out
how to document this how to create it
and how to make it work but if you were
comparing apples with apples and you
were
documenting a house for example a very
simple 4x2
generic think of the most basic box you
can think of
autocad would probably take you three
times if not four times longer
to document this actual house versus
archicad
now from a business point of view and
from an entrepreneur side of things
archicad means you're making four times
as much per
hour versus four times as little per
hour
now obviously yes autocad is three times
cheaper so if you are doing only
six thousand dollars worth of jobs a
year autocad is definitely cheaper
because you're four thousand dollars in
front
but if it takes you a full year to do
six thousand dollars worth of work
you could probably do four years worth
of work
with archicad so all of a sudden instead
of making four thousand dollars
you're making somewhere upwards of
eighteen thousand dollars a year now
this is a question that people ask me
all the time
what about 3d visualization in autocad
if it's a 2d software
well you have to remember that autocad
is still owned by autodesk
the company that makes revit and revit
renders are actually
really really good so once you know how
to use autocad properly
then you can actually create some semi
decent renders
inside the software itself if you want
to send it off to the revit cloud or the
autodesk cloud
you can create some really really good
renders so
don't be afraid and thinking that just
because you're going with autocad you're
not going to have any good renders you
will however on the other hand
have much better renders through
archicad
because of a variety of different
plugins such as twin motion
i swear these guys should definitely
sponsor this channel because
i talk highly of twin motion all the
time i really enjoy the program and i
enjoy using it
so twin motion allows you to render
photo realistic
animations in either a still image or a
video
vr walkthrough whatever it is very
powerful and with integration of unreal
engine 4
which is some of the highest cinema
quality rendering software out there
it is only getting more and more
powerful you can actually export an
autocad file in to twin motion but
it isn't a direct link so if you found a
mistake in your model
you'd have to go back to your autocad
file fix up the mistake export out that
file
import it back into twin motion
re-upload it change all the elements and
keep working
whereas with archicad and revit as well
it has
a very simple direct link plugin so you
find a mistake
you fix it you click sync it fixes it
automatically there's nothing more for
you to do
so again it's about that time management
and efficiency
in archicad versus autocad now let's
talk about the pros and the cons
the pros for each are kind of simple the
price
is more of a con for archicad than it is
for
autocad autocad is relatively cheap up
front and ongoing cost
archicad is a very expensive upfront
cost
but you get what you pay for i believe
speed on the other hand is a con for
autocad
it takes you a lot longer to do
something on autocad than it does on
archicad so archicad definitely wins in
this category here
from a design ability and design freedom
point of view
in the architecture specific area they
both do really well
you can design absolutely anything that
your brain can think of
from a non-architecture specific
category autocad
is a lot more flexible and free to do
whatever you can think of
whilst archicad is a lot more generic
and limited i guess
to the architecture profession knowing
that you can import
3d objects which have full color and
texture and materiality
in them in archicad is a huge win for me
because it means i can go in and put a
whole living room in
and model it down to the last detail if
it's
the throw rug the pillows the rug on the
floor
and finally i think a big pro vs con
scenario out of everything i talked
about
isn't 3d modeling isn't any of that it's
more so
the scheduling and the automation of
documentation
understanding the fact that
documentation is such a big part of
architecture and it's
the make or break between something
being built and something
sitting in your cupboard for the rest of
your life is a very important factor
so the fact that archicad has inbuilt
scheduling that can automatically pick
up all your doors and windows
and anything else that you might require
versus
autocad where you kind of have to
manually estimate the area of walls and
understand how much paint you might need
or how much landscaping you might need
it's not as simple
another great feature about archicad's
3d library is the simple
fact it introduces a 3d like button
so if you want to go ahead and smash
that like button to help the algorithm
and help this channel grow
that would be greatly appreciated so at
the end of the day what's my verdict
well i think if you don't have the money
to spend on archicad which is a very
very expensive upfront cost then autocad
is
clearly the right decision because for
350
a month it gets you into the game it
gets you into the software
and it gets you practicing your skills
and your craft if you do have the money
on the other hand and you're not
debating between these two softwares
based on that
hands down it's a very very simple
decision
for architecture at least if you're
doing architecture archicad
is the very clear and obvious choice
between these two programs
anyway that's all from me today guys
thank you so much for joining me i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that like
button it hugely impacts how this video
gets thrown around youtube and how the
algorithm works
so again it is genuinely appreciated if
you do and if you want to see more of
this content make sure you subscribe as
well
anyway that's all from me i'll see you
next monday